>>Student: So we're testing
if it's soluble now.
We'll test conductivity, density,
and then make a diamond table after.
>>Brenda: I feel really good about
what's happening in my classroom.
The students are really engaged.
I don't have as many students off
task because they're really interested
in what's happening in the classroom.
>>Patrick: The vision of
Maloney High School is
to create student centered environments
where kids have more opportunities
to prove their learning,
to explore their learning.
We want students to be problem solvers.
>>Brenda: To make your
lessons more student centered,
you want to think about
what your role is.
You as the teacher act more
as a facilitator or a coach,
rather than the person who
disseminates information.
We have some student
centered learning tactics
that we want happening
in our classrooms.
They're a really great way for
teachers to plan their lessons.
>>Patrick: The first
approach is to find ways
that the lesson can engage
student to student discourse.
How can students work together?
>>Lindsey, group one, right there.
>>We want kids to be in groups
that will make them successful,
where students can not
only express their ideas,
but also learn from each other.
We're trying to get every single student
to have some hand in the learning.
>>All right, so we'll do what
we usually do with the poem.
We'll read it out loud together
first, and then you're going to react.
Did you like it, did you dislike it?
What do you think the poem is about?
"Shall I compare thee
to a summer's day?"
>>Ethan: Today we analyzed
sonnet eighteen from Shakespeare.
Having a few students around
me is extremely helpful.
We'd analyze it and pick
apart even the smallest things
that I would never look at.
>>Mia: I don't get the middle, like--
>>Jake: The beauty of winter's
going to go away eventually,
like her beauty will never.
>>Mia: Anyone can interpret
a poem differently.
When you're in a small
group and you're just
with your peers, it's less intimidating.
It's like, okay, I can share my ideas
and not be afraid of being wrong.
And when you're talking that way,
I feel like you understand it.
>>Patrick: Student choice
and student ownership
over the work is also a curricular
element of student centered learning.
Step two of the lesson,
students were responsible
for deconstructing each scene
from act three of "Hamlet."
>>Do you guys want to work
like, in pairs or you want
to do something each individually?
>>One group did a mind mapping exercise,
where they took the key elements
of the scene that they were assigned.
Another group decided that they
wanted to do their own performance.
>>Mia: When a woman takes
a second husband,
it's because she killed off the first.
>>Jake: Harsh.
>>Patrick: So the students
had ownership.
They were able to explore
what they wanted to explore.
At the heart of it was analysis.
Do they understand what these
characters are going through?
Do they understand what
Shakespeare is trying to get across.
>>Jake: He runs away
because he's guilty.
>>Mia: End scene.
[applause]
>>Brenda: It's easy to have everybody
sitting down quiet and taking notes.
It's hard to get everybody to think
outside the box, but that's what's going
to happen in a student
centered classroom.
It's going to look a little bit
chaotic, because not everybody's going
to be doing the same thing
at the same time necessarily.
>>So we've been learning about
chemical bonds, and now what we're going
to be doing is an enquiry lab.
>>You're giving the students
all the tools that they need,
but then you're asking them
to come up with their own lab.
You're really figuring out
what they've understood.
>>You have six unknowns.
You might think you know what
they are just by looking at them,
but now you're going to
have to use your knowledge
of chemistry to prove what they are.
>>Jake: All the substances
look exactly the same.
They were white, they were powdery.
Right off the bat we knew,
well, they're not malleable,
they're not ductile,
can they be conductive?
>>Brenda: My role is to facilitate
what they were doing, so I would listen
to their questions, maybe answer
their question with a question
to have them delve further
into their knowledge?
>>What do you think you
have to do with it?
>>Jake: I'm guessing you've
just got to stick the end in.
>>She gives us a little bit of
direction, but she doesn't give us a lot
of direction, and it's
frustrating in the beginning.
But as you dig deeper and deeper and
deeper, like, it becomes more fulfilling
than if she told you what
exactly to do, because you feel
like you're being a scientist yourself.
>>Oh, it went up...
>>Brenda: Another student centered
approach is authentic tasks.
So what the students did was something
that a chemist might do in a lab.
Some students created data tables
and others were creating graphs
and looking at the trends.
>>Student: Two seventy-seven
point seven.
>>Jake: I definitely feel like
student centered learning provides us
with a better outlook of what
real life is going to be.
It feels like you're experiencing
something rather than taking notes
on something, memorizing it and
having a test on it the next week.
It's fun.
>>Brenda: I think the students
here are starting to realize
that the teachers are
really in this yes mode.
And so they're asking more for
these authentic opportunities.
>>Mia: It makes me feel like I'm
taking control of my learning process.
It's my choice and it's what I want
to do with what I want to learn.
We're asking questions and we're doing
activities that help our understanding.
>>Patrick: The student centered learning
approach has been beneficial to me.
For seventeen or eighteen
years, it was always,
what am I going to tell the kids today?
And now it's, okay, what am I going
to have the kids show me today?
>>Student: It's kind of like
a more hopeful beat, like...
>>Patrick: Yes, that's perfect.
>>They're showing me
what they're learning,
and the person who's really kind
of blown away by that is me.